hey guys I'm Ryan right let's be crazy
and be Seibert so we're gonna watch the
trailer today for halo 5 guardians is
that what it is yeah I think so
yeah you just look good huh I'm rode off
by [ __ ] up my name
I like halo a lot it's a lot of fun for
me I recently started playing Halo 4
finally mm-hmm it's a it's it's a blast
it's a blasty blast I have a great time
it's it's really fun
I think the point I'm trying to convey
is you'll have a good time good job
buddy really bad who made this game
this is 343 studios got it got it right
this
using me this [ __ ] I just like a love to
find legends
do now with the hens with MA
I tell people that I trust you
yes
the seeds hello our prayer so you're
really gonna get to actually explore in
this time floor like it seems like
you're learning about Master Chief like
the reason was become a mystery you yeah
that's that's what they said about this
trilogy is that they're trying to show
who he is now okay give him a little bit
more humanity so it's likely after four
it's a like a couple years after four
really yeah they said they're gonna go
to his past morning so I was like well
interesting see Master Chief's like
legit past that be pretty [ __ ] sweet
yeah origin sort of eat it feels
personal this time just find it funny
that says your journey begins but if
this is a trilogy than for was the
beginning this is more like the mid but
I'm okay with it
reading it I'm not complaining anyway
guys if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe here to the real rejects
we have a lot of [ __ ] on here and you
get a that's the word subscribe to
Alyssa's channel Elissa be crazy where
she is out of her [ __ ] mind and you
could subscribe to Dan's gaming channel
where he sits in his underwear and plays
Super Nintendo it's really fun is uh I
have played Super Nintendo
yeah it is what's gaming with that with
with pants's it's but if you guys can
figure out which videos he is not
wearing pants in Dan will personally pay
you $1000 let's not let's let's uh
what's not 1000 ourselves there right
look I don't make that much 1000 I don't
make that much in person I gotta make
rent doesn't matter where you live I
live in LA there's too much money he
could be in China you'll fly there I
just bought my tickets for Thanksgiving
yeah sweet sniper 69 he said can i get a
shout out please and i would like to see
a porno between Ryan and Veronica please
thank you I think you're probably the
only person who wants to see that what I
don't know it I did the real water look
I'm gonna try to be as classy because I
meet a you know I wanna
a gentleman a little bit of a head stop
right ahead but stop while you're ahead
don't don't go there I'm just saying if
stop let's say like you know the movie
sex tape and here's a shovel just go
ahead and dig yourself a bigger hole the
movie sex tape right when you're like
doing this the sex tape with your girl
I'm not saying we've done it or we're
gonna do it you know what yeah you're
right we're done
sniper 69 you made things awkward
rebellious Johnson he complimented me
and then he said anything for the
awesome real rejects and he wants a
shout-out rebellious Johnson dude listen
there's no need to be a rebel without a
cause anymore my friend respect the
Johnson two pieces of advice lies fight
the power
whoa rules are meant to be broken oh
yeah
listen you be crazy man hey you don't
fences are put up but you can always
open them you can always climb over them
doesn't mean you should but you can so
you should you learn the rules before
you break the rules this is good because
most of our subscribers are actually
from Mexico so this works that well
racism humor racism here I thought we
were giving sound advice [ __ ] I thought
that word every started an advice column
it would probably be the best thing ever
I don't know I mean the three of us I
wish they said advice but I'm pretty
sure like some would say like hey man
this this this and after I'd be like oh
[ __ ] that's what I clarify I have plenty
of Mexican friends so some people is it
make it okay some people no I'm not
saying it doesn't make it okay I'm just
saying I'm not a real racist just you
know there's like a sensor button
someone my girlfriend's half Mexican oh
hey look another giant shovel get taking
Brian irizarry
you're lucky guy Ryan and I honestly
love you and the rest of the rejects you
always sir Mike yeah I remember him you
always turn my bad days into good ones
oh by the way Veronica was reacting to
the shout-out request it seems like is
most likely the reason why she hasn't
given you a chance oh because there's a
person who was saying like Veronica
get with me huh and then he was saying
that like yeah that sounds like rhonchi
won't get with you because of how you
are well guess what Brian you were wrong
not everything is as it seems
you were wrong I appreciate you hee-hee
like plus ones my stuff a lot guys an
awesome oh yeah he's a great guy
yeah I were like I miss dude like a
novel those are always so much fun to
read instead of people that are like hey
what's up give you a shout-out this
guy's like actually gives us something
to work with it's great great now I have
to read a lot of novels cuz you good job
thanks man everyone's gonna leave the
longest comments and then people are
gonna be like you didn't get back to me
everything's because I'm um I'm like on
the second column you Leela I enjoyed
the novels I enjoy actually hearing what
people have to say instead of just like
hey what's up doesn't mean I like novels
if they really mean it and I like it but
I'm saying some people are gonna
intentionally just write a bunch of [ __ ]
I just like people
whatever damn your the hatred in your
heart would you know my warm heart will
warm everyone's here's a shoveled and
dingus is that three yes I feel like we
need to end on a joke you're right